do you think um
body count matters oh yeah and what how
many is too many
more than me
wait what are you like you're beating me
and then black man wait what are you at
i'm not admitting that over a lot more
or less than 20.
higher
so as long as she has a lower body count
than you what if she had one lower than
you would you be freaked out no i'd
laugh you'd be like [ __ ] all right
i'll keep my number higher because i'm
sleeping with you
the moment i hear your number goes up
well so she had one more than you then
you'd be like no
cyan or a [ __ ]
within a few okay without like maybe
like five i think that i slept with more
people than i needed to but
um but you can't really judge her if you
did the same thing yeah
okay the man of fear would disagree we
all make mistakes that's my opinion on
it okay
next question do you think that guys
should be allowed to cheat if they make
a lot of money and they're paying for
everything no
cheating is wrong all the way around i'd
[ __ ] that
would you ever stay with the girl that
cheated on you because you dumped the
last bit
two two not the last one the one before
last one i mean i still kind of talked
to
okay
see in the menosphere they think it's
okay to cheat
when you have options and you're like
paying for everything because they feel
like
basically you're trading like
your resources for women's like goods
and services like
loyalty basically um okay but next
question next question
next question um
do you
who do you think has it harder in dating
better women woman by far you think they
have it harder
really why
um
my favorite i forgot who said this my
favorite thing was
um if someone finds it quote them okay
it was
men or women get to choose who they
sleep with men get to choose who they
marry
right
well i actually i think it's harder for
women for two reasons right
women have a clock that's ticking
and so
even even when you're young like i don't
need to be married tomorrow right but
i'm well aware that i don't have like i
have less than a decade to like figure
out who i'm gonna marry because at 35
it's like a high-risk pregnancy
so you gotta you gotta get your [ __ ]
figured out before that
and the second reason i think it's
harder for women is it's very hard to
decipher the difference
um between someone giving you attention
and wanting to like date you
or just one yeah oh sorry yeah yeah yeah
yeah
we're men
i guess it's hard for men too though
because some rose will definitely use
them for like food
food funny yeah
but for men it's a lot more obvious
because you're able to
you can be a lot more clear about
hey
you can
you just take away the things that they
that you provide the most for them and
you see how they react and that's easy
to
face i'm gonna go over here while we
finish this video
it's easy to gauge how
you can figure out if someone's using
you very quickly just by taking a thing
or two away versus woman say i lost my
job see if she stands there yeah versus
woman if you take away stocks you're
taking away it for both of you it's not
just yeah one step like if i stop paying
for hannah's meals all it does is give
me more money like that's nothing bad
for me but like when do you pay for my
meals
[Laughter]
and like
i feel like girls that you have the risk
that if you sleep with them he could
just ghost you tomorrow and then you've
given up like
you know um
remember
um okay
what other questions are they gonna ask
you in the manosphere
so i asked you about so wait how do you
go up to 25. did you say you'd marry a
25 year old yeah okay
yeah they'd have to be amazing but
they'd have to make up for it
just
i don't
i don't think i'd ever marry someone
that isn't amazing overall yeah
okay what about um
do you care about a girl's money
not really
so she doesn't care about money and all
together but
do you care about her ambition yeah she
has to be driven
motivated as hell
um if i'd start a business tomorrow she
has to be willing to help me
run it and work through it and
just put up with my [ __ ] while i'm doing
it like you can't just
can't be someone that sits there and hey
yeah cheerleader what if what if she
started a business would you be willing
to go and help her
oh really so you'd be cool with like
going on like hurt like if she had a
business going you'd be totally good
would you be cool if she made more money
than you
yeah
i'd be a little upset but yeah if she
was paying for my [ __ ] i wouldn't care
he's super competitive so i feel like i
feel like you would i feel like you
would try to like beat her i would i
would that is true i'm very competitive
but growing up
this uh austin and everybody's siblings
were gonna be competitive like okay what
are your deal breakers
um
it doesn't want kids
that's it
i don't know if i want kid yet but i
have to be able to make the decision
without any um without any bias
she can't she used to be open-minded and
motivated
someone was lazy he's just not gonna
do it
he has to be fit too i'm not i'm not
doing fat [ __ ]
[Laughter]
how um could she be taller i mean you're
pretty tall what if she was like six
three six four that'd be [ __ ] cool
i'm gonna have some dope ass kids
so you'd be cool for girls taller than
you you're literally a girl she was like
driven oh yeah she i'm her little king
he's pretty tall so it's we're pretty we
we make them big in this family
okay i think that's all my manners oh do
you
think it's a turn off if a girl is like
i hate men like men are trash have you
ever say that 100
um i'd sleep with you just for the fact
that i could prove a point of hey
it's not it's not the [ __ ] men that
are trash it's just that you make poor
decision with men that's what i always
say like when you as a girl say men are
trash you are communicating
i
i sleep around basically that's my
thoughts
i get ran through like i hate to say it
i don't want to be the one to say it
but i can't stand those those people and
like same thing goes for guys that say
women are trash a god do you guys say
that i've heard a few but they're
usually
because of a former breakup or something
something okay do you think that player
is like do you think of the biggest f
boy you know
cheater okay
do you feel like he was made to be a
cheater or born a cheater like do you
think did he get his heart broken and
became a cheater
or did he was he just made i think it's
lack of control i think you made
yourself you just you don't have
discipline discipline and self self um
responsibility you don't take
responsibility for your actions and
self control
okay would you be cool if you were
dating a girl and she went out to
parties every weekend
you're in college that's pretty normal
in college but i'd say post college
that's not super normal yeah um
i could see it in the future being a
problem but like i just i wouldn't
really care as long as i trusted her if
if she ever put the doubt in my mind
it'd
make me nervous what if she was wearing
a super revealing outfit would you be
cool with that
because i feel like the only reason that
she would wear that is to get attention
i want attention too i don't give a [ __ ]
we want attention so you don't care if
she like flirts with other guys or gets
attention from other guys as long as
she's not like hooking up with them
doing anything with them if she's if
she's even making out with them that's
too far but well no no i meant like just
like
oh my god you're so funny brad you know
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] brad's gonna
buy her [ __ ] four drinks and she my
tab's gonna go down because of it
that's the funny thing in the man of
spirit they're very like insecure about
like girls going out and stuff and i
don't even think it's necessarily for
bad reasons a lot of girls do cheat so
um you know fair enough but
isn't it about 50 50. like because i
thought it was both ways it's about even
um so according to the nanosphere it's
men do slightly higher but by like three
percent it's about 25 to 28.
yeah which i mean that's they're about
the same number and i would guess it's
probably half if you accounted like
flirting and stuff
um
i like i feel like when people think
cheating they think like have i kissed
or like done anything
i mean i agree i mean that's what it is
you can flirt all you want like
it improves how you are
as just in general day-to-day
relationships as well as you can flirt
really well and then like you can relay
that back to your significant other
that's just even more fun
just things to practice i don't know
i would not be cool with the flirting
i'm too i'm too jealous i do not if
you're doing it in front of me then yeah
i'm gonna be like hey [ __ ] chill but
um
behind my back i'm not gonna ever figure
it out because i just don't care um
part of it is i don't care enough to
actually look into it and be if i'm
dating you i trust you there's there's a
level of trust like i
i don't date people in general
usually just because i don't trust many
people but if i'm trusting you to date
then i'm gonna trust you to be able to
go out on your own and do [ __ ] on your
own and i'm gonna trust you to be able
to
not cheat on me i don't have the control
and the cheater the girls that have
cheated on you you've cut off like it's
not like he
drug them along or did anything like
that like he he said no
no no no no
okay that's all my manuscript